[Music]
put your seat belt on yeah follow Mike
all the towns of no go its wake up
people damn dangerous people we're
dangerous people
I need to tell you something okay good
my second BC I'm about to throw up oh
you bet - he'll not get his hand stitch
leather you better drink
[Applause]
[Music]
you are Papa all right meet at the club
at 2300 you see so we're your Sunday
best this is a grab or in we're out
nobody's this raid is strictly non
lethal non-lethal but has anyone
informed the bad guys aclu realms rubber
trust me you'll enjoy them you get to
shoot as much as you want bad boys bad
what's she gonna do what's she gonna do
no never
y'all will never do that again excuse me
excuse me
right stop right there oh no Marcus we
fly together we die together
what oh no that's just somebody say it's
all good in oh I can see how that got
y'all oh we got from whoa where you get
all the toys DEA stationed in Cuernavaca
you capture her they take the credit get
ourselves killed
you got nothing to do with it all eyes
will mean I'm the bait we meet at
Hidalgo palace it's an old hotel outside
the city I'll keep her talking so you
guys spot the shooter
well she shoots you know she's gonna
want to talk okay
rap we get him and we're on a plane back
to the States my god don't give me a
floor plan satellite energy we'll have
eyes on the outside and on the inside
[Music]
[Applause]
tight pants and fence cars don't make
you Batman
[Applause]
get me the [ __ ] out of this car we got
more time behind us than in front ahead
please I'm gonna be running down
criminals till I'm 100 not me on guitar
this time we be good men
who the [ __ ] wants to sing that song my
putting on a new team you're working
with ammo now okay ammo is a high school
musical boy band we guns look great
grandpa so you're that guy there's
always one right up till there's not
that's what I like teamwork
[Music]
Marcus somebody's trying to kill me who
wants to kill you I don't trust a person
that don't wanna kill he'll put my name
up thanks a lot we got it Marcus we
appreciate it
but family it's the only thing that
matters so I'm not letting you go on a
suicide mission alone
one last time one last time
[Music]
Henry get all these helicopters
oh this is my wife's car cover the front
door she knows he always knows it's so
interesting when you come back together
on a movie after this long there's such
a deep love for these characters and for
this franchise the first one was 23
years ago which sounds crazy well I'm a
lot heavier I love 1 & 2 and I just
wanted to get back with you again to do
it because people need to see us again
on camera yeah we made the characters
real are you ready to bust this case
open yeah let's finish strong and in 3
they gonna want to just ride with us the
yin and the yin and the yang absolutely
is rare but is beautiful to be able to
come back together and everybody's still
handsome that's why we have chemistry
because you say it's nothing like that
[Laughter]
[Music]